[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich habe mir überlegt euch zu
zeigen wie ich eine schmuck aufbewahrung
bachtel weil ich einfach generell das
problem habe ich habe es nicht so viel
schmuck aber ich habe immer das problem
die ketten verheddern sich die hängen
weil mir momentan im bad über so einen
türknauf und ich habe mir gedacht das
ganze kann man doch ziemlich stylish
machen und dann hat es leider ein paar
ideen zu viel ich glaube das video hat
ein bisschen aus und ich zeige euch
jetzt wie ich hier hinter mir diese ecke
ich hab dann nämlich so eine kommode
stehen und wie ich diese ecke jetzt war
schöner und vielleicht habt ihr lust das
ganze mittwoch mit zu verfolgen
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal sondern
sessel geholt der mir einfach farblich
super gefällt ich werde jetzt noch farbe
aussuchen für die wand weil ich glaube
ich werde die wand auch noch mit
streichen
dann machen wir ein bisschen schmuck
aufbewahrung für die wende für den tisch
und ihr könnt bestimmt für euer zimmer
für bad kinderzimmer schlafzimmer
einfach auf was mitnehmen und gucken wie
ihr vielleicht den schmuck zu hause
aufbewahren könnt und wie ihr so ein
paar deko-ideen abholen können also wenn
ich jetzt erstmal eine farbe aussuchen
und dann moral zum baumarkt schicken und
ich fange dann schon in der werkstatt an
[Musik]
ich wollte eigentlich voll das schöne
bruder rosa und der saat oder rosa ja
das weiß ich jetzt auch aber ich werde
ihn trotzdem oder rosa machen müssen
egal
eigentlich wollte ich das ist in die
richtung geht aber der sessel ist
du hast jetzt j ja ich weiß nicht ob mit
dem ich so dunkel wird ich glaube schon
ich glaube okay ich mache so ich nehme
hibiskus 3 oder hibiskus 2
ich nehme mir bis 3 okay hier bis drei
leben
[Musik]
also momentan habe ich alle meine sachen
okay nicht alle aber einige hier drin
den schmuck ständer hier habe ich
eigentlich mal für samira gekauft für
ihr zimmer habe ihn dann einfach
kurzerhand für mich benutzt aber die
kriegt sie jetzt wieder zurück und ich
sagt sie hat man einfach so die ketten
kann man schon schön aufhängen aber ich
habe sie heute für meine arme greifen
wenn einer aus stecker die ich halt
vertrag einfach kein platz
und deswegen gehen wir in die werkstatt
und werden jetzt schmuck aufbewahrungs
dinge okay dass ich nicht immer noch
also ich muss sagen die idee zur ketten
aufbewahrung die habe ich auf interest
gesehen da kann man sich nämlich aus dem
ausland irgendwo es ohne ketten
aufbewahrung bestellen aus holz und ich
habe mir gedacht nie kommen die können
wir auch selber machen und zwar haben
wir bei uns hier in der garage immer
ganz viel restholz so bisschen sperrholz
man kann sich aber auch einfach beim
baumarkt kaufen und sogar zu sehen
lassen also ihr müsste theoretisch nicht
mal selber segen sondern ihr könnt zum
baumarkt gehen und einfach die maße
durch geben
ich denke ich werde zu den maßen her
eher etwas längliches brauchen so wie
hier ungefähr nicht ganz so hoch weil
das wäre mir jetzt schon zu sperrig aber
ich kann ungefähr sagen also von der
breite her würde ich schon auf etwa 10
11 cm gehen und von der länge her
ungefähr auf 30 das ganze braucht es
natürlich noch einen fuß ihr könnt euch
das so vorstellen dass liegt hier später
so hochkant ist ein leicht angeschrägt
damit die kette schon drauf liegen und
ich mache hier so einkerbungen rein
damit ich die kette einzeln hinhängen
kann und so verhindern sie später auch
nicht mehr und ihr habt es einfach schön
übersichtlich und jetzt brauche ich
dafür einen fuß den kann ich aus holz
machen oder aus beton und so werde ich
später machen und damit ich später
einfach auch eine form hat für die
rettung für den rettungsfonds werde ich
mir gleich eine form zurechtschneiden
aber jetzt geht's erst mal ans holz und
stahl schneide ich mir jetzt gleich das
master und zeichners an aber wie gesagt
ihr könnt auch zu beschneiden lassen
ein bisschen einfacher also das brett
hat jetzt hier so knapp 18 cm knapp
unter 18
ich werde jetzt einfach halbieren das
heißt ungefähr
8,75 und da könnte er das so machen ihr
nehmt so eine klammer packt sie hier an
was er haben möchte und dann können wir
das nämlich mit einer bewegung direkt
machen hier ansetzen bleistift dran und
dann entlang ziehen
okay da lege ich das jetzt kurz zur
seite
das ist praktisch meine ketten
aufbewahrung und jetzt mache ich noch
eine aufbewahrung für armketten ohren am
reifen und dafür habe ich jetzt hier und
holz in verschiedenen stärken und das
könnt ihr euch jetzt so vorstellen dass
ich in der mitte sondern mast ab und
dann hier so kleine querstreben und da
kann man dann alles schon aufbewahren
und da macht das am besten so gezeichnet
euch ungefähr auf wie es haben wollte da
gucke ich muss ich tatsächlich sagen
auch wieder auf interesse so ein
bisschen nach ideen aber ich schreibe
ich dann die masse die ich genommen habe
auf jeden fall ganz exakt rein da kann
man sich dann überlegen ob man eben
einen querbalken macht oder mehrere oder
die sogar versetzt sagt macht
[Musik]
für den mittleren mast nehme ich jetzt
hier dieses rundholz mit eineinhalb
zentimeter durchmesser und für die
querstreben hier mit dreieinhalb cm und
ihr guckt einfach selber wie hoch und
groß haben wollt wie viele querstreben
drin sein sollen ich mache jetzt zwei
habe ich jetzt mal so vor und schreibe
euch dann auch die genauen maße
natürlich alle dass schneide ich jetzt
auch vorne kurz zu benutzt einfach mal
eine tischkreissäge zum abschneiden
ganz wichtig einfach immer geschlossene
haare und einfach die arbeitssicherheit
immer beachten
[Musik]
um ein holzbrett jetzt zu halbieren
nämlich es hier den parallel anschlag
dann wirklich alles sauber abgeschnitten
wird und einfach zur sicherheit noch
hier die abdeckung und einen skistock
zum schutz meiner finger
perfekt halbiert und jetzt zeichne ich
mir hier am rand noch die einkerbungen
an und ich denke ich werde sie so in 3
cm abstand machen
nach unten hin dann keine mehr denn da
kommt ja noch der betonfuß und dann kann
ich hier schon bestimmt sechs bis sieben
ketten aufhängen kann euch hier im 3 cm
abstand schön am rande auf beiden seiten
an zeichnen
[Musik]
und die einkerbungen hier die müssen
natürlich nach unten gehen damit die
kette hier schön drin hängen kann wenn
ihr eine tischkreissäge habt klappt es
echt ganz gut ansonsten zeige ich euch
jetzt eine alternative
ich sage ich das mal hier an meinem
reststück wie ich das mit der handsäge
machen würde und geodreieck habe ich
jetzt aber ich zeige es euch so markus
amt also wenig ein geodreieck gehabt
nehmen die einfach euren zollstock
einmal hier an zeichnung das wäre so die
tiefe und dann würde ich hier anfangen
hier oben die 3 cm
wir markieren und dann etwas isst mit
versatz nach unten
und dann muss man sie nur noch verbinden
[Musik]
man hatte hier auch immer schön den
gleichen winkel und jetzt baut ihr
gehende mitte ein loch dann habt ihr
nämlich schon mal eine schöne rundungen
hier in der mitte und entweder nehmen
die jetzt ein schraubendreher oder so
eine an reis hilfe markiert einmal hier
das loch das hat dann den vorteil dass
der bohrer gleich nicht verrutscht
und ich nehme jetzt sehr einfach so 1 6
mm war hier ein loch und immer ein
untergrund nehmen also in ein anderes
holz rheinbahn damit sie mich ausreißt
und ihr seht schon dass der bohrer
wirklich einen schönen halt hat
[Musik]
und dann käme ich mir das jetzt hier
rein das nicht habt braucht einfach zwei
hände und im prinzip gut da eigentlich
jedes säge ich muss dazu sagen die hat
glaube ich jeder zu hause weil die in
jedem set mit dabei ist und für mich ist
das jetzt auch so persönlich die hand
liste und dann einfach hier zweimal
segen so dass ihr praktisch einmal
rechts und links vom loch entlang sieg
nicht ganz die eleganteste lösung
funktioniert aber ich mache meinen
schmuck aufbewahren jetzt an der
gespräche mit der höhe des segel platte
ist bestimmt man jetzt praktisch die
tiefe des schnitts ich hab das ganze
jetzt schräg angestellt und kann jetzt
hier einfach schön rein schneiden ohne
dass ich's geodreieck brauche und ich
habe einfach perfekt geführten wasser in
der störer vom cover der musiker wind
mitarbeiter also was ihr machen müsst
ist hier die zwischenräume auf jeden
fall schleifen der papa immer schön
abschleifen perfekter wm gerade
festgestellt der papa nicht wir haben
kein 14 mm bohrer für die runde variante
hier also nämlich noch 10 mm und 10 mm
rundholz das passt auch aber wie gesagt
erst mal abschleifen einmal die
zwischenräume können das schleifpapier
einfach so umknicken damit ihr beide
seiten habt könnt ihr gerne einmal noch
mal über die oberfläche entweder auf
einem schleifpapier oder mit so einem
extra schleife geht halt einfach
schneller
[Musik]
unser den vorteil dass ich teilweise
noch flecken weg bekommen wenn es nicht
mehr so ganz schöne
[Musik]
das holz ist perfekt vorbereitet
das einzige was mir nicht gefällt ist
die farbe deswegen weit sich das holz
jetzt noch ich habe hier so eine
wasserlösliche pulver bei 10 und dem ich
mir jetzt einmal mit heißem wasser dass
jetzt die farbe nußbaum dunkel denn ich
jetzt einfach gern bisschen dunkel und
dann kann ich das jetzt einmal
ausprobieren
aber ich finde es richtig schön so mach
ich es ich nehme jetzt die handschuhe
ein weg habe ich nicht gefunden aber die
lasse ich einfach in der werkstatt meine
werkstatt handschuhe und jetzt einfach
schön das holz beize ich finde es sieht
jetzt dadurch sofort viel edler aus
[Musik]
richtig genial hier noch die
zwischenräume nicht vergessen
die holzbretter lasse ich jetzt kurz
trocknen jetzt habe ich hier meinen
rundholz die habe ich ja bereits
zugeschnitten für die am ketten
armreifen
da werde ich mir jetzt einfach in der
mitte den punkt markieren und wird dann
einfach ein loch durch bohren damit das
rundholz durch passt also einfach bei
allen hier einmal die mittel markieren
[Musik]
das nächste mal mache ich nicht gerade
zahl jedes mal muss sich komma fünf
rechnen 33 2
[Musik]
im besten falle läuft so ab dass das
ganze hier reinpasst und sogar so schön
eng ist dass sie man es nicht leiden
muss passt muss man nicht leben
da oben drüber geschliffen sieht man es
auch kein übergang mehr
und darum wird es jetzt schön
einbetoniert das habe ich jetzt
vorbereitet wenn es aber jetzt noch
vorher kurz beizen dass es auch farblich
wieder dazu passt daher auch meine
werkstatt scherzer & co
[Musik]
mein papa xhaka also schickten langen
jungen mit dem krieg so josch max also
beide ok wachstum beim vater raus oder
sagte papa der andere lange der papa ich
brauchte news zum film und dann kam und
dann kam der monats dann habe ich dann
im rat nicht sanierten kurze brauchen
apa
[Musik]
dann hab ich jetzt erstmal alles gepasst
und sobald die bei zu trocken ist was
ist jetzt bei den flachen holz und schon
ist kann ich das ganze versiegeln des
bbi wasserfarbe und auch wasserlöslich
das heißt wenn jetzt wirklich wasser
drauf tropfen würde wird halt auch
wieder abgehen
also hier noch einen versiegelung slug
tapezieren den matten denn ich will ja
auch schön macht belassen
das eben gut durchleuchtet so gut
durchlüfteten räumen oder draußen machen
jetzt ist hier alles schön getrocknet
und versiegelt und damit die ketten da
später schön dranhängen können und nicht
runter rutschen auch von der länge her
möchte ich hier hinten noch nägel dran
machen das heißt ihr sucht euch jetzt
die vorderseite die habe ich die drehe
ich jetzt weg dann einmal die mitte
markieren
[Musik]
und jetzt am besten vom ersten punkt
hier versetzt weiter unten anfangen
es können euch entweder kurz aus messen
oder den ersten punkt einfach mal
festlegen und dann eben wieder in 3 cm
schritten
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach schöne
nägel mit seinem größeren kopf und
schlag geht es aber so ein bisschen
schräg ein so dass die kette da auch
wirklich einfach dranhängen kann nicht
soweit durchschlagen natürlich
[Musik]
damit ist den kleineren nagel jetzt auch
getan wenn der morgen blau ist dann
mache ich auch blau
[Musik]
bevor jetzt betoniert wird wirklich
alles schön bereitlegen das heißt hier
kleine rundhölzer die ketten
aufbewahrung ich habe meine formel 2
eckige hierfür dann zwei runde
da nehme ich den größere hier und den
kleineren hier
ich habe noch kleine hölzer die brauche
ich gleich und dabei wirklich alles
schön bereit legen damit die veto macht
sogleich nicht so schnell fest wird und
ihr wirklich gut alles aufarbeiten könnt
dann ein bisschen draht der ist für die
stabilität da also den könnt ihr euch so
ein bisschen zurechtbiegen sowie die
form eben auch ist unterhält dem bett um
dann gut in form und stabilisiert das
ganze eben aufpassen dass er nicht am
rand rausguckt also klein genug machen
und jetzt kann ich hier die klausur
anmischen ja stark das machen wir jetzt
nach gefühl also mach was nach gefühl
und ich brauche jetzt würde ich sagen
eine gute feste rührteig konsistenz es
hier schön mit der küchenmaschine lieber
mal etwas weniger aber jetzt noch schön
klopfen damit sie es verteilt hier auch
die reste sowieso einen teig schaber
wegnehmen dann kommt jetzt hier parteien
seien
[Musik]
jetzt gibt's noch ein paar ohrstecker
und ohrring aufbewahrung und dafür nehme
ich ganz normale bilderrahmen die gibt
es auch in verschiedenen größen und
verschiedenen materialien ich habe ich
jetzt die rückwand ausgelöst zum einen
möchte ich jetzt eine aufbewahrung aus
kork machen also habe ich hier auf der
rolle einfach gekauft es gibt aber auch
schon solche kochplatten sogar mit
waffen der rückseite und die sind auch
schon in der schönen form also so könnte
man das ganze auf gestalten und kann ja
auch zum beispiel diese form von
übertragen auf spiegel zum beispiel ich
nehme jetzt allerdings die rolle und ich
denke dass das dann eine schöne
aufbewahrung gerade für so steckt zum
beispiel ist klappt das heißt ich messen
jetzt einfach hier in den bilderrahmen
aus und schneit dann die kochplatte
dementsprechend so habe ich hier 11,5 x
16 5
[Musik]
also ich habe es ganz so ein bisschen
geglättet und gelebte sitzt hier rein
mit doppelseitigem klebeband
[Musik]
jetzt setzt erst mal dass wieder ein
jetzt die kochplatte
[Musik]
und ich glaube ich werde das nicht mal
hin hängen sondern vielleicht hinstellen
als ich das nochmal die option offen als
sie es doch hinhängen rechte kann ich
hinten immer noch was an schrauben zum
an die wand hängen aber ich lasse es
jetzt erstmal so
[Musik]
das ist ganz cool also ich finde es ein
bisschen locker geworden
hier ist auch ein bisschen ein gewissen
ich frag mal gleichwohl kam den beton
experten ob ich vielleicht was falsch
gemacht haben ein problem
das ist manchmal wenn das ist so viel
geld die klicken oder das ist nicht
genug sand oder bis nicht ein
wir müssen immer die stellung des sans
santin gute promotion zum beispiel bis
33 mal songs und einmal ich hatte extra
sohn fertig so eine fertigung sei es
nicht getan am seil banker selber immer
gut gute medien betonen und gute sache
und gute mischung und nicht so viel
wiegt dann klebe ich das jetzt einfach
rein damit
als nächste mal bei mir schon mal besser
selber an und amazon beton workshop dass
so etwas nicht mehr passiert jetzt zeige
ich euch wie ihr aus bilderrahmen eine
tolle ring aufbewahrung machen könnt als
er beziehe nur den rahmen den
hintergrund brauche ich nicht hab hier
einen festen jute stoff den gibt es im
bastelladen also das ist der dem eben
auch zum sticken benutzt und es schneide
ich jetzt eben in der größe zu ein
bisschen kleiner darf es ruhig sein und
dann mag ich das ganze hier an den
inneren rand also nicht hier hinten
drauf denn wenn ihr es hin hängt an die
wand dann ist er das direkt press an der
wand und dann könnt ihr keine ruhe
darüber hängt also wirklich an den
inneren rand am besten schon mal so eine
knick falte machen dann legt sie es gut
rein und dann am besten aufrecht
hinstellen und mit dem tucker hier
direkt renntag am schön auf spannung
also erstmal die eine seite und dann die
gegenüberliegende
[Musik]
perfekte würde ich sagen sieht echt gut
aus und das ganze kann man jetzt mit so
schlichten rahmen machen oder mit so
barockrahmen die könnt ihr vorher sogar
noch ein bisschen an sprühen wenn euch
die farbe nicht gefällt und je nachdem
was für ein stil ihr habt passt der eine
oder der andere rahmen eben ganz gut bei
euch rein
und wenn es hin stellen wollt solltet
ihr die rückwand noch mal benutzen falls
ihr es hinhängen wollt einfach hierhin
was zum aufhängen hin machen falls eben
nichts da ist jetzt hier auch meine
töpfe noch angesprüht denn da möchte ich
meine kleinen pflanzen deswegen auch
handschuhe denn ich hatte neulich schon
kaktus spitzen nadeln wie heißen die
dornen botanik expertin kakteen dornen
in der hand und zwar recht sehr
schmerzhaft und beim einpflanzen muss
man beachten entweder setzt man sie mit
seinem ihnen töpfchen rein so dass
einfach das wasser abfließen kann oder
man nimmt hier diese diesen blättern als
wird ohne in einen topf weil ich hoffe
sie überleben jetzt habe ich hier sogar
spezialkarten erde
[Musik]
schön dass jetzt hier schon aussieht was
einem topf einfach ausmacht in der
richtigen farbe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gut dass jetzt auch erledigt jetzt zeige
ich euch noch eine schöne aufbewahrung
und zwar gibt es hier diese schmuckdosen
da kann man ganz tolle schlecker oder
zum beispiel auch ringer darin verstauen
und wenn ihr sowas nicht findet oder
nicht habt und sagt ich habe meine
lieblings box da möchte ich es gerne
rein machen könnt ihr euch einfach eine
leere box nehmen das kann auch zum
beispiel süßigkeiten schachtel sein da
gibt es ja mittlerweile auch echt ganz
tolle verpackungen die man einfach
aufheben kann und eben ganz toll
verwerten kann
und dafür braucht ihr einfach ein
bisschen filz also bastelt aus dem
bastelladen die breite sollte dann so
sein wie hier also wie die aufbewahrung
bei mir passt sogar schon fast ich muss
es nur minimal zu schneiden und dann
braucht ihr entweder rundholz oder alte
stifte oder zb strohhalme die brachte
nämlich für ihnen rein zur rolle und ich
zeige euch jetzt wie das funktioniert
ich möchte jetzt hier die breite meiner
box aus das sind jetzt hier 19
übertragen auf meinen fans
[Musik]
den stift oder das holz schneidet ihr
ein bisschen kleiner zu dann geht es
einfacher rein in die box
[Musik]
und dann gebe ich das ganze heißkleber
an und wickelt den stift ein
und je nachdem wie dick die rolle sein
soll
solange oder so kohls muss eben auch
dass vieles sein ich probier's mal
einmal im kompletten optik ist aber ich
finde das passt
[Musik]
also da mir jetzt hier vier stück gut
gefallen klebe ich jetzt auch das ende
schon mal zu damit es nicht wieder
aufrollt
[Musik]
aber das muss jetzt aber mal texte
direkt das ist schöner aus viel
hochwertiger als dieses billig ding
schon so für stecker und ringe aller art
das letzte mal habe ich jetzt einfach
aufgehört weil ich keine wasserwaage
hatte jetzt habe ich endlich eine alte
ich spreche jetzt hier einmal ein
rechteck vor und clips dann gleich ab
und mit der wasserwaage funktioniert
wirklich am allerbesten
[Musik]
fertig angezeichnet nämlich ein bisschen
klebeband zum ableben und clips so ab
dass ich immer so minimal außerhalb der
linie bleibe damit die linie im inneren
bleibt und die eben später überpinseln
kann dann sieht man den bleistift
nämlich nicht mehr
[Musik]
denn hier innen schön drücken dass er
später bleistift jetzt ein bisschen aber
ist nicht schlimm denn nur auf dem
klebeband
ihr könnt natürlich auch ein breiteres
benutzen aber falls ihr auch nur so ein
schmales habt einfach doppelt kleben
dann habt ihr keine gefahr dass sie aus
versehen raus machen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich die weiße wandfarbe die
ich auch als untergrund habe und kann
jetzt mit einem pinsel hier den übergang
versiegeln das heißt in zum klebeband
streichen damit später die bunte farbe
die ich dann an die wand mache eben
nicht nach außen dringt und so habt ihr
dann in schönen glatten übergang
das ist jetzt so wie bei fondant orten
die erste schicht die krümel schicht die
stopft die löcher und sorgt dafür dass
später die obere schicht also davon dann
runter fahre eben glaub auflegt und wenn
ich das jetzt nicht sauber macht dann
habt ihr später auch kein sauberes
ergebnis also nehmt euch dafür kurzzeit
[Musik]
also schritt eins ist jetzt schon mal
erledigt die farbe muss sich jetzt
natürlich antrocknen lassen
in der zwischenzeit können wir uns einen
leckeren smoothie und dann geht es
manchmal
[Musik]
jetzt ist hier alles getrocknet eine
farb- probe habe ich ja auch schon mal
gemacht ist ein bisschen zu rosa aber
ich glaube am ende passt und jetzt rolle
ich hier die fläche kurz ich nehme es
einfach eine kleine rolle ich so ein
mini einer habe vom mini kleinen
gemischten 1
doch ist eine schöne farbe ist ja auch
mein mädchen zimmer kommt wieder wie
gender diskussion warum mädchen baum
rosa weil ich ein mädchen bin und rosa
mark und ich arbeite jetzt immer erst
mal am rand entlang dann werde ich nicht
aus versehen darüber male das kann
nämlich schnell bei mir passieren wenn
ich abgelenkt bin singe und dann die
volle fläche führen
[Musik]
ja man könnte jetzt auch eine große
rolle nehmen und werde natürlich sofort
fertig aber da wird es schon
außerdem habe ich nur so einen kleinen
eimer und ich meditiere dabei
die wand darf ist trocknen ich finde die
farbe echt schön finde ich gut und
sobald sie getrocknet ist das klebeband
ab
und dann geht es gleich mit der band
dicke weiter ein erstes mal auf 1.213
moment einfach ausgemacht wir probieren
es gleich an anderer stelle normalen
bitte gib auch scala fließt england den
hätte ich jetzt gerne hier
[Musik]
ja mein gott
jetzt gleich schwindlig davor auch schon
das erste decke oder wand hängt wie
schön
die aufbewahrung die kommt jetzt bin ich
hier drin
einfach kurz mit einem nachteil dass er
nicht so schwer
ja
[Musik]
ich immer so die kunst das zu treffen
haben eine stahl ich nehme jetzt noch
soviel zugleiter hier unten drunter so
macht ihr euch eure möbel und tische
nämlich nicht kaputt damit nicht
zerkratzt und alles schöne besteht
[Musik]
repplinger darf ich ja panik paar lebte
muss an machen ach so
[Musik]
er verlegt war wie die ecke hier vorher
ausgesehen hat jetzt ist ja echt schon
richtig schön jetzt hole ich einfach den
schmuck hängen rein und dann bin ich
fertig
[Musik]
ferrari bücherecke professionelle samt
rocker streicherinnen
[Musik]
ich finde es so schön
ich glaube ich komme einfach nur noch
hierher und gucke mir die ordnung und
dann geht es mir gut am abend
[Musik]
es hat doch mehr arbeit als gedacht also
eigentlich wollte ich ursprünglich nur
die ketten aufbewahren machen
dann kam baureif aufbewahrungs ständer
dazu dann noch die ohrringe dann noch
die idee mit den hängenden ohrring ok
und dann kam irgendwie die ganze nische
hier zustande
jedenfalls habe ich es geschafft bin
fertig und ich finde dass man echt sagen
muss dass pflanzen sondern brauche ich
cool aufwerten also ich finde so ein
bisschen grün hier da oben hängen ich
auch noch von pflanzen hin macht das
ganze schon ein bisschen wohnlicher und
schöner und jetzt habe ich endlich
klappt für den schmuck habe alles schöne
griffbereit und vor allem schön
aufbewahrt und vielleicht habt ihr euch
ja die eine oder andere idee aufholen
können
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare und
schreibt mir auch gerne welches durch
das l4 als nächstes sehen wollt was wir
auf jeden fall auf unsere to do liste
haben ist das baumhaus der kinder also
das spielhaus das wollen wir noch ein
bisschen verschönern und da denke ich
nehmen wir euch auch ganz einfach mit
also bis zum nächsten mal tschüss
[Musik]